I'm here on YouTube to talk about the
economy and the environment because
clearly they don't have enough people on
the internet talking about this issue
now we're here at the dot in Davos at
the Economic Forum and here's what's
going on where will the money go will it
go to energy will go to the environment
or will it go to pump up this economy
now there's a lot of smart people here
who say that they can do both so we'll
see that in wind energy will see that in
a smart grid that they're talking about
now the stimulus package in Washington
we'll see it all around the world but
the question is can you save these
industries can you save the car
companies can you save consumers who are
leaving their houses in droves can you
save all of it at the same time I wish I
had the answer but I know it's somewhere
on YouTube you guys go look for it thank
you